porque por ejemplo en suecia todos los
niños hablan inglés porque la televisión
es siempre en versión original y la
mayoría en inglés inglés inglaterra o de
eeuu
[Música]
buenos días dave cómo estás muy bien
gracias y usted es bueno ahora tenemos
dos gringos que van a hablar en español
porque nate tiene un canal en youtube
donde ayuda a hispanohablantes a
aprender inglés pero también integraban
en inglés a aprender el español si yo
entiendo entiendo ver bien es así no si
quizás tú puedes presentar un poco tu
actividad o actividad lo que estás
haciendo claro bueno creo vídeos
entretenidos en youtube en español a
veces en inglés también para inspirar a
la otra gente a aprender nuevos idiomas
en este caso inglés y español pero si es
mi meta más entretener a la gente
mientras estoy dándoles una educación se
puede decir
pero el aprendizaje de idiomas debe ser
bueno y divertido
entonces no hay una contradicción entre
aprender y divertirse claro y yo
a veces pienso que bueno en la escuela
tradicional
siempre tenemos la idea que necesitamos
un profesor que la educación se hace de
un modo una manera
sin crono no al mismo tiempo están y por
eso ahora que con el hobbit las escuelas
están pensando cómo va a hacer la
escuela online y siempre el modelo es
éste sin crono hogar y el profesor que
va a hablar a través del zoom y todo eso
pero para mí lo que tú estás haciendo es
también instrucción educación pero él
los dientes no pueden escuchar y mirar
tus películas cuando quieren claro que
no es síncrono esa sin crono y tenemos
esta idea de la educación que debe ser
sin crono al mismo tiempo no pero para
mí no toda la mi aprendizaje aprendizaje
de idiomas es cuando yo quiero al tiempo
que pasa para mí cuando estoy
conduciendo en mi coche o lo que sea que
pienses tú sobre esta distinción o como
que digamos así con el cover que va a
cambiar en la educación y sobre todo en
la educación la instrucción de idiomas
es interesante creo que
va a cambiar mucho por la razón qué
personas ya se han dado cuenta de que
aprender otro idioma puede ser por en
línea o sea no hay que tener una clase
en la vida real o en persona sí
pero bueno también creo que sí como
dijiste es importante que las personas
también se dan cuenta de que
se puede aprender otro idioma haciendo
cosas más divertidas como viendo vídeos
en youtube escuchando música podcasts lo
que sea pero sí creo que ha cambiado
pero
sí sí
a mucha resistencia de la parte de los
profesores porque por ejemplo en suecia
todos los niños hablan inglés porque la
televisión es siempre en versión
original y la mayoría en inglés no
tinglado inglaterra de eeuu
si por ejemplo alguien que está
aprendiendo el español en la escuela
digamos en eeuu
creo que puede aprender más escuchando
tus vídeos que en la clase que se puede
decir y también como dije creo que
porque mis vídeos son más entretenidos
personas pueden divertirse más viéndolos
en vez de estar leyendo unos libros
escuchando a un profesor así que estoy
de acuerdo y espero que eso sí pase
porque es mi meta ayudarle a la gente
aprender más
sobre los idiomas claro de una forma más
entretenida
tengo la impresión que en el internet
hay muchísimas
bueno como decir posibilidades no como
tu canal como otros en youtube hay tanta
posibilidad de buscar cosas de su gusto
claro
para aprender y quizás el profesor debe
más guiar y sugerir a los aprendices
cómo buscar cosas de su gusto a su nivel
nivel y no enseñar el idioma y de este
modo
pues una pendiente también alguien algún
alumno en la escuela puede aprender
cuando quiere puede jugar con sus amigos
cuando quiere que podemos cambiar esta
estructura de sentarse en la clase y
aun si ahora que no estén en la clase
que están en online pero no diré todo
eso
al acontecer al mismo tiempo que alguien
puede
escuchar mucho y progresar muy rápido y
otro más lento y que tenemos es para mí
la enseñanza de idiomas es demasiado
estructurada y este tiene que cambiar
las cosas que tú estás haciendo es un
ejemplo
pero hay muchos como yo como tú como
otros claro claro claro
muy bueno y de dónde vienen sus
adherentes mismas que se considera
miembros la gente que aclaró es claro sí
bueno de todos lados si son las de tengo
muchas personas argentinos y personas de
colombia méjico también los estados
unidos y bueno pues todo el mundo y eso
es bueno porque creo que personas cuando
me ven y ven que puedo hablar español a
un nivel más alto
y aprendí en la secundaria y con amigos
les inspira aprender
español o inglés que uno puede la verdad
no puede aprender otro idioma no tiene
que ser algo tan difícil sí y yo he
visto algo algunos de tus vídeos
y muy interesante tú hablas muy bien en
distintos como dice variaciones de
español puedes imitar el españa
el español de yo no sé de colombia del
chile d
venezuela méxico claro
y tú sabes también la acogida es line de
todos los países ha viajado mucho en
américa latina yo he viajado a méxico
y para ella españa pero no más esos
países que si no más méxico y me parece
que hablaba con el acento local con los
plan de jones ecuador otros países así
no no hablo con unos modismos el slim de
méxico no de méxico hoy claro porque es
vivo en el sur de california así que
aquí hay muchos hispanohablantes
mexicanos regreso tengo un acento más
mexicano a veces personas me dicen que
tengo un acento colombiano pero creo que
más mexicano o también más es neutro
también fue
en el mundo de los hispanohablantes no
es enorme y es muy muy rico la mucha
variedad de culturas distintas como
cuando fue en perú por ejemplo los incas
con mucha música muchas muchas cosas es
un idioma que verdaderamente vale la
pena
aprender a aprenderlo no sí y la
variación de pronuncia no es tan grande
como en inglés para mí a mí me parece la
diferencia entre españa español hablado
en yo no sé argentina méxico españa no
hay tan gran diferencia que existe entre
el inglés de escocia de australia y su
desde texas no y tampoco la diferencia
que existe entre el portugués de
portugal de portería es depresivo
entonces el español es más o menos muy
muy bueno parecido las variaciones salvo
a pesar de que hay esas leyes que varían
de país de país pero la pronunciación es
más o menos lo mismo para mí
bueno y dónde vienes tú yo vivo en el
sur de california
jaja en los ángeles
bueno bueno
ten cuidado al estilo precio un montón
de alarte bueno a mí también muy gran
placer y mucha suerte igual bye bye bye
[Música]